hallo mein Name ist Luca meine Damen und
Herren ich habe bereits dreimal quizzes
gespielt die ihr für mich erstellt habt
von daher
mache ich das heute wieder wir starten
mit dem Quiz für laserlaka von Jessie
aka con__loogie auf Instagram und
natürlich sind Nancy mal Robin und Chima
auch wieder mit dabei
ich bin gespannt
Frage Nummer eins wie oft dreht sich ein
Mensch im Schlaf
[Musik]
ich würde sagen ein Mensch dreht sich im
Schlaf nicht allzu häufig vielleicht 10
bis 20 mal also ich mache eigentlich
30 bis 80 was Bruder Frage Nummer zwei
wie viel Prozent an Duftstoffen sind in
einem earde Parfum oho ich bei Jerry
frankons im Raum chillig wie viel
Prozent an Duftstoffen ich glaube das
ist relativ viel und zwar 10 bis 25%
. glaubt mich kenne mich aus mit Parfums
ich stinkt zwar sehr doll aber ich kenne
mich wirklich aus mit Papa was verstehen
Sie Frage Nummer drei wie oft atmet der
Mensch innerhalb einer Stunde ein und
aus ich würde sagen warte dass mir kurz
erzählen
wir sagen 20 mal ach
eine kiffen ich würde sagen 30 bis 40
Mal pro Minute also das mal 60 so
ungefähr 1000 mal
ey 900 mal das ist so nah dran Frage
Nummer vier fliegen Autos so schnell wie
Giraffen was das für ein Schwachsinn
ich in den Porsche Auto als Flugzeug mit
einer Giraffe im Gepäck man kennt ich
würde einfach mal antworten was
[Musik]
einige Monate haben 30 einige 31 wie
viele haben 28 Tage das ist eine
Scherzfrage denn tatsächlich haben alle
Monate 28 Tage
ab jetzt mit Ansage alles richtig wie
oft ist man Spinnen im Schlaf ich glaube
gar nicht
[Musik]
irgendwann ist mal so ein Bild bei
Instagram damals noch viral gegangen wo
gesagt wurde dass man angeblich 12
Spinnen im Jahr ist wenn man mit offenem
Mund schläft aber das stimmt da einfach
nicht aus welcher Höhe springen
Fallschirmspringer hä
4.500 oh nein Sandra ey das ist doch so
ein Schwachsinn immer eure Bilder hier
ich würde sagen 4.500 Meter
[Musik]
ich hatte ja selber schon 20 falsch im
Sprünge halt's Maul dritt letzte Frage
warum reagieren Stiere bei der Farbe rot
aggressiv deabonniert laserluca chillig
weil sie rot hassen da die Farbe Rot in
ihren Augen brennt weil sie rot Farben
sind oder weil sie darauf trainiert
wurden nie weil sie rot hassen
tatsächlich
als sie rotfarben blind sind
wie hoch kann ein Känguru springen ich
glaube zwei Meter habe ich mal irgendwo
gehört da zwei bis drei Meter
ich bin so eine Maschine und die letzte
Frage wer ist cooler okay er ist cooler
Jessie Malin alle drei kommen
[Musik]
das sind die drei Idioten über diese
Quiz ist für mich erstellen kommen wir
zum siegerp
odest Quiz auf
der ist doch nicht anders verdient auf
der Nummer 2 haben wir
bis für Quadratlatschen von Malin aka
lugi unterstrich der Unterstrich Lauch
Frage Nummer eins mit welcher
Geschwindigkeit ploppt ein Sektkorken
aus der Flasche ich
bin der Sektkorken wir haben hier
ehrlich gesagt nur relativ geringe
Auswahl und zwar alles nur zwischen 10
und 50 km/h ich hätte allerdings gesagt
dass der locker 100 km/h schnell ist
aber gut wenn die schon so fragen würde
ich 35 nehmen weil sie die einzige
ungerade 40
lassen wir zählen die 5 km/h das ist
Toleranz wie beim Blitzer Frage Nummer
zwei welches von diesen Lebewesen hat
die dünnsten beide ja wahrscheinlich ich
[Musik]
nett eine Mücke hat dünnere beide als
ich sehr schön wie viele Treppenstufen
hat der Kölner Dom boah ich glaube 400
irgendwie dann 351
ich bin den schon hochgelaufen das waren
definitiv weniger also hier würde ich
mir auch einen Punkt geben wie viele
Songs werden pro Tag auf Spotify
hochgeladen ah laserlacker stimmt mein
neues Lied wie viele Songs werden pro
Tag auf Spotify auch gar nicht ich würde
sagen 10.000 mehr können das nicht sein
es ist 80.000
Songs
das kann doch nicht sein Frage Nummer
fünf wie viele Jahre unseres Lebens
schlafen wir 20 bis 30 24 würde ich
dementsprechend sagen
ab jetzt mit Ansage auf welchem Bild ist
Luca zu sehen oh ein Ratespiel auf Bild
1 haben wir Hamburg
[Musik]
das Gewicht eines Regentropfens beträgt
boah keine Ahnung ah chilliges Bild
wieder ich ich werde gar nicht mehr auf
diese Bilder eingehen das machen bringt
mich einfach nur aus dem Konzept ein
Regentropfen wiegt glaube ich 0,08 Gramm
[Musik]
letzte Frage ab welcher Wassertiefe kann
man nicht mehr furzen
10 Meter
du kannst da immer furzen oder wie viel
Liter pinkelt man im Jahr ich würde
erstmal auf den Tag beziehen
[Musik]
ich würde es erstmal auf den Tag
beziehen oh ich habe eine 17 Sekunden
zumindest zwei Liter von da würde ich
sagen im Jahr 540
ich habe eine Fünfer Antwort Serien ne
von daher kommen jetzt auch schon zur
letzten Frage in diesem Kurs was ist der
Plural von Octopus oktopie
Octopus ich bin trotzdem ganz ganz easy
auf der Eins was das ist alles scam
komplett Betrug
wenn ich jetzt beim letzten Quiz für
heute dem Quiz vor evolutionsbremsen 2
von Mona LKA wirkpunkt Lords of
Instagram wenn ich da jetzt nicht erster
werde ich lösch meinen Kanal komplette
Konzentration was steht die Abkürzung
DHL
[Musik]
werden nicht gesagt ein paar Sekunden
später
[Musik]
ich habe gerade ein Bild davon gemacht
weil ich das cool fand weil das eine
witzige Idee wäre und dass ich überlegt
habe das zu machen man macht ihr denn
jetzt 17 Sekunden Zeit müssen
anscheinend ein bisschen schneller sein
von daher wie hoch ist der Kölner Dom
meine Damen und Herren wir müssen es
richtig haben so schnell es geht 234
Meter
[Musik]
aber warum bearbeitet mich eigentlich
immer auf den Kölner Dom irgendwie drauf
Frage Nummer drei wie heißt die Firma
Carglass in
Englands repair glass würde ich sagen
Carglass heißt Autoglas in England
wie lange wartet man im Durchschnitt an
einer Supermarktkasse ich würde sagen
was im Durchschnitt boah 5 Minuten
maximal wenn ich
sieben ich habe bisher alles falsch ist
eine Tomate Obst oder Gemüse boah ich
weiß warum Gemüse ja wird beides wie
schnell war die Titanic als in den
Eisberg gefahren ist ich glaube das ist
eine Schere was heißt Scherzfrage also
die sind auch alle relativ schönes Bild
auch alle relativ geringen hier aber ich
würde wirklich sagen nicht schneller als
40 kmh
ich dachte auch diese Kreuzfahrtschiffe
sind deutlich schneller Frage 7 von 10
wie viel Zeit in seinem Leben verbringt
ein Mensch auf der Toilette falsch
geschrieben
schön schön ich würde sagen ein Mensch
verbringt in seinem Leben tatsächlich
zehn Monate auf Toilette
ja es kommt auf den Menschen an bei mir
sind safe 10 Monate auch wieder betrug
hier alles welche Gummibärchen Farbe ist
am beliebtesten tatsächlich die weißen
glaube ich
[Musik]
also ich liebe auch am meisten die roten
aber ich kenne so viele die sagen die
weißen schmecken am besten vorletzte
Frage wie hieß Super Mario bevor er
Mario hieß ich glaube
ich habe einen Bart auf dem Bild ich
glaube Mister red wahrscheinlich nee
Mister video
ey sorry der hier jede Frage ist doch
gelogen oder letzte Frage für das
heutige Video wie lange können
Kakerlaken ohne Kopf über
mir egal hey ich bin nicht mehr auf Top
3 wahrscheinlich hier schaut euch das an
ich bin nicht mal Top 3
lol blöde Kuh bin aber auch zwei safe
Nancy Robin dann ist Nancy safe auf der
einzieht immer irgendwie oben mit dabei
[Musik]
[Applaus]